mr. glad company i Salam aleikum peace
be unto you we got brother Phil born and
get big born-again Christian he was
contemplating purpose of life realized
I'm going to die one day so he became a
born-again Christian he went through the
whole party scene became a born-again
Christian and he left that for this what
is this we're going to be talking about
it this way of life that was brought and
taught by Jesus Moses Abraham and the
last final misery problem hon peace be
upon him the way of like this from the
create or not organized religion
organized by man or men the way of light
that brings you peace prosperity success
in this life and paradise and the next
we're going to hear his wonderful story
this French Muslim here on the Deen show
this
this is the this is the beam you Salam
alaikum peace be with you
Heineken sorrowful over the cat how do
you see what I introduced the show I was
like you know French you know I never
had a French brother on the show big
deliver France a wheeze buff myself
so how do you how do you say how you
doing Frank French if you wanna me place
a comment allez-vous call it down the
level and mashaallah flowing a lot I see
a lot of French Muslims that's where
they got to the car band right yes
that's in the job and Frances it's it's
in Europe uh-huh in Canada it's a ham do
lots of rocking lots of Algerians that
came down
yes sir last what's the predominant
religion in France I would say it's
Christianity yeah so you were born-again
Christian
yes what does that mean born-again
Christian like you were dead and now you
become born as you found I found the
daylight of Jesus Christ if you yeah I
had lost my religion at one point and
then I did something terrible and I want
to you know go back to what I knew know
my source well my roots and I decided to
pick the Bible read it from A to Z you
read the whole Bible read the whole
Bible yeah and nine a night we emerged
myself in Christianity did you read the
original Bible and we both know it I
didn't read there is no bio there's no
original by there's absolutely no is
there a copy of a copy of a copy of a
copy of anything original translation
and in a version there's nothing there's
no nothing close to original not today
so you read a today what we have today
what we have to do what's claim to be
the Bible today yes and I accepted Jesus
Christ as my Lord and Savior the whole
thing about the Trinity and the Son of
God is that you had the G I call it the
JC go-cart you put all the sins on JC
that's the ones Christ
get-out-of-jail-free card as well yeah
yeah and he quit before that what were
you doing with your life before then if
a lot existed or he didn't exist just be
a good person it doesn't matter
no but you figure out that you know man
has to have a purpose if you were to
take away mosquitoes from
the planet within a few months
everything dies let me just took away
what the mosquito in the scale is a fact
right that's a fact mosquitoes
mosquitoes but if you take away mankind
nothing happens so this whole ecosystem
this whole wheel this whole cycle does
it need you so why are you here
you have to have a specific purpose and
you were thinking purpose well of course
I mean if we know why a pen is made you
know why it's created it's to write but
mankind which is obviously way more
complex than the pen what's his purpose
in life you know so at one point you put
all your eggs in one basket and
Christianity so we're so now you're
thinking purpose what's the purpose of
life with your parents practicing
Christians they believe in God they
believe I've seen Jesus the Son of God
the whole nine we think we think French
I'm sorry we think you know what France
is like Canada yeah you're Canada but
when we think French we think like wine
people on the beach I mean like Dali
you know this whole like of course I go
to a bunch of in France you like really
aren't in Canada sided they're different
cultures okay we're really two different
cults so now you're in Canada and you're
not obviously following the way of your
parents you're just having a good time
and then now you start you did you go
through all of the good times and now
you're thinking purpose of course what
drew you to think about it because it's
a it's an odd topic for a lot of people
because they're wrapped up with music
absolutely you know partying so they're
locked up in this illusion of fun and
pleasure and so that's what I want to
know how did you because we want to get
people unlock from that how do you get
unlock to even get to be in a born-again
Christian the thing is you are going to
die I am going to die we are all going
to die
so when I did this terrible Act is opana
like what am i doing what am i why do I
feel so bad when really it shouldn't
matter why is this ingrained into my
being as though it's part of fitrah why
is this why am I like this
so I went back to the book went to the
Bible so that's when you're living
according to your desires of course so
you want you you're feeling something
missing there's something missing for
sure there's something missing
we can't we have this culture this pop
culture like we make kids believe that
they will live forever they will live
forever but it's not the case where you
were you really into music of course
nightclub nightclub
I was I was 16 when I first became when
I became Muslim 15 16 years old how
young I was young hamdullah
who's young yeah but nightclubs not yet
you know illegal but - parties for sure
I did the whole nine you know back in
the day and it's just I snapped out of
it you snapped out of it because it's
someone that did some what did you have
like a a life altering situation where
you almost died no no it's nothing like
this it's just that I did something bad
but why is it by what we feel so bad
about it why or do we fear death all of
a sudden no is someone's like what did
he do
of course like what I do like what was
it was it something specific it's it
between me and the creator for now
they're military yeah yeah but and it
just went back to the book became a born
again and I thought Jesus was the key I
was preaching on street corners you have
see friends were born-again Christians
that were like doing Dow it to you they
were invite you to this it was it was
the opposite I went to them be like guys
we need to pray drinking lunch hour you
know what are we doing you know and then
Dennis in the hallways we're talking to
this we were talking about this bad
stuff we need to go pray and we were
sitting in a circle and we were praying
the whole night it's what we it's what I
believe Jesus was one a Trinity of Corti
for your sins that presents clear-cut
belief if you don't believe this that's
it and everyone else is going to help
everybody else is believe that Jesus
died allegedly Jesus died your
assistance teaching us this was the
fundamental message I would ask people
do you believe in God yeah I believe in
God do you believe in Jesus no and it
would break my heart because I thought
that was the only key give us an example
K you see someone out there and you go
up to them to to give them some what
would you call it like - like preach I
was preaching you know reach the word
given a good word yeah another chord you
tell John 3:16 for God so loved the
world they send it on would you just go
for someone to say look man you never
met the guy how'd it go it was did you
just come up - hi my name is L Phil yes
you know God so loved the world exactly
so sometimes you would have pamphlets
you know he talked to people and do
believe on what do you think happens
after when you die you know is there is
there light at the end of the tunnel
what happens these are good points
there's a very good point even Muslims
today can use what I
after death but I would always cling it
back to the original sin listen mankind
is a sinner so you cannot ever be
forgiven here you have to believe in the
blood and sacrifice of Jesus Christ and
it will just entwine that that belief
and with reality and just be like that's
all you have to believe did you ever
speak in tongues no you know Paulo it
was a did you see people speaking in
tongues I've seen on YouTube but never
like to go ever go those conferences the
conventions where they got the guys and
they're like in Canada they're not too
big they don't I don't I haven't really
seen it they do happen they do have
people talk about it but there's a lot
of theater involved I believe there's a
lot of money isn't it Oh a lots of money
if you buy this soap and washes away
your sins you know like big took us more
tell us more
so in Christianity and then afterwards I
met a very special brother we sat down
you know it was in grade 10 grade 11
where I sat down for Muslim I've been
with Muslims with all my life very
multicultural back on the Canada and no
one ever spoke to me about Islam we
worship God you guys worship Allah no
it's just a different language you know
I'd say I worship God and you worship
dear here's how you say God in fact it
doesn't matter so he sat down with me
and asked me is Jesus the Son of God
well of course this is a son like what
are you talking about you know you know
this and it just started from there and
for the next four months
it was transition after transition until
I accepted Islam all my life never ones
that I understand no was it about Islam
did that appeal to you
what was it that now you were a
born-again Christian you were hardcore
John 16 all the way oh yeah all the way
my Islam now Islam the thing is people
today's Pamela in the conference we talk
about Islam it sounds foreign it comes
from I believe in Jesus you know the
letter j j-- jesus never said that the
letter j never mentioned that it's a
phonetic that he never heard he never
heard this never heard Jesus Jake yeah
never heard it so Mohammed it sounds
foreign
sounds like a guy cooking up the
shawarma you know so but when you really
understand it and you see that Jesus I
leave he said peace be upon did the same
behave the same under the prophets
landed
you realize that you're not changing
shirts you just retailer in your suit
it's not a different belief you're just
adding a few tweaking it a little bit
and that's what really drew me and I
said founded there's something here
there's something here and spinal after
four months of going back and forth
Tauheed 101 you know here one of these
pyramids 'm who is Muhammad The
Messenger of God Salah Haleiwa Selim who
is Jesus the true identity of Jesus and
you actually take the time to read the
Bible specific verses that jesus prayed
with his head his face hit the ground
and he prayed so he didn't eat pork he
behaved a very specific way he pushed
people to do good deeds believe and then
do good deeds he taught people to not
descend stay away from sin if you're
Isis take it and cast it away better to
be in this world war along with
absolutely no fire and the Prophet SAW
some says avoid hell fired by half a
date they're preaching the same thing
same message the same message and this
whole idea of like he copied from Jesus
that means Jesus copied from Moses and
Moses copied from a ram now they come
from the same light and it really drew
me to this Jerusalem just a know through
through back and forth conversation and
not ham delight today I can say I'm a
Muslim because because of this one
specific brother Allah made him the tool
that guided me to Aslam we have a lot
more questions I asked you signal that
we got to go to break and we're going to
continue with your short story is that
okay that that sounds like a plan you
speak a little French for us or
something that something up Liz it all
right we'll be right back here on the D
show with brother Phil it's simple to
understand Islam means submission look
at the word submission not to yourself
not to your desires not to anyone or
anything because at the end of the day
you get something you always want more
you get some weed you want more you get
some drugs you want harder drugs
you got aggro you want a nicer girl you
get a car you want a nicer car you get
on a nicer house we've got so many
precious by enslaving yourself
worshiping God loving God but submission
to the one who created you and by
worshiping going and seeking his
pleasure
you get pleased
that would be good
this is my family
but he's always been stubborn he started
having his problems getting up clearly
fights one night policeman told me my
you ready sir father come on get him
from the station he's locked up one
fight here another fight there his
physical beam was great for Zito but it
left him in see if someone who Eddie in
his youth they would predict that he'd
be dead and the outside people looking
in today this is the man
everybody knew Eddie and then he give a
moment a 78 women that are running
around the club looking fine I have to
get out of this totally right now at the
end there was just a boy it was a
constant struggle there was in her soul
was broken at that moment there was that
emptiness in his eyes it was a big round
Tina's that I think I've ever really
seen in his eyes I'm running here
running there and mainly I'm running
that long way it was dr. Jekyll mr. Hyde
and he was struggling with that but the
effort was there there's a conscious
effort to make that switch he bags
started talking to his back look at him
it's fine idea good guy
this was the reality it was dead ladies
con supposed you wanted starts on the
slide and spread it to the non-muslim
but people didn't know who I was but
what why are we doing this I also take
you serious you're living a dream and
people were just stubbornly resistant
and I started looking at you like you're
you know from outer space
I have to be out there and trying to
convince people to be on the show of
that show aired I think that's when you
saw the for pollination coming to so
hope these guys change what's going on
here this is a machine I know see
someone change to see their character
changes to see positive changes in their
life it's a sign of God revenue Bevan
you welcome back welcome back my fella I
like all right Ron Ron tell us brother
Phil yes this is a really serious topic
because this is something that really
scared me - the reality of deaf-owned
you know people dying everyday everybody
and you know when you're wrapped up and
your mind is just cluttered with all
this nonsense that's a waste of time you
know and then when you start thinking
serious and you ask serious questions
and you really find out what the true
purpose of life is course you're happy
you're content obviously have struggles
in life life is a test I'll do paradise
is in the next slide not in this line on
its life so tell us what happens now
okay you become a 'muslim what's the
final breaking point you said you're
going back and forth debates dialogues
you know the final breaking point was
when I accepted that God is unique
nothing resembles a lot a giant old
completely unique and all these
attributes in his adjectives they're not
yet Muslims out there yeah you know
they're hearing a law what would defy so
there you go Allah is actually like two
words put together this is one the
beauty of the Arabic language it means
the one worthy of worship it is neither
male nor female and it is singular it
cannot be put in plural form so Allah is
unique one normal no female when I say
God I could also say goddess what I
choose to say God I'm adding a meal sort
of like figure to this this being nuts
beyond this world and that's it that's a
problem so when I say along very
comfortable because I know exactly the
this actually what it means so they know
continue on from here perfect when I
realized that Allah Azza WA JAL is
unique and that Muhammad sallallahu sent
peace be upon him is his final prophets
after him there shall be no more is how
there shall be no more
I told my cenote I believe you know like
so if I believe it's good enough you
know but again take a step back the
reality of death is still there I can
party have fun for 60 70 80 100 years
but where will I go afterwards it is
eternal you don't come back it wherever
you go you stay there so if you you
cannot compare a hundred years to
eternity one reason is nothing it's not
even a split second it doesn't exist
compared to eternity so you just got to
put all your eggs in the right basket so
on my way to school I was alone when I
took my Shahada sure I should have been
in front of people have witnesses but I
was alone I say you know what I'm going
to die so it could be walking home just
walking back from home school we don't
know
so I testify that God is unique I
testify that Allah is the true god no
and Muhammad sallallaahu some is his
prophet and messenger and that day I
became a Muslim and I sort of knew how
to pray coz through the four-month
discussion I sort of you and we were
just starting Ramadan Salah we were just
about to begin and all that funny story
is prior to that to my Shahada I didn't
want on the previous year to see just to
get an experience out of it because
Jesus fasted for forty days but today
you don't eat chocolate for forty days
during Lent but it's supposed to be a
fast but anywho so walking to school and
I remember death again and subhanAllah
my purpose is to be a Muslim but the
purpose of mankind is to submit to allah
azzawajal
back to the story of the mosquito if you
take away mosquitoes from Planet Earth
everything dies but mankind things
improve or or allocate we don't add
balance to this world so what is your
purpose and the logic clearly states it
well ma khalaqtu l-jinna wa l-'insa illa
liya balloon except for worship we're
not here to thirst in order complete the
cycle of plants and then the bees and
pollenization and we have nothing to do
with this of course we have an impact
but that chain doesn't need us our
purpose is different it's how how can
people be convinced as you are a hundred
percent because when you get into I'm
sure the Trinity God because the
Christian Creed is God is Father Son
Holy Ghost of course but one
they're one now we try to figure this
out you know it doesn't make sense it
doesn't mix it doesn't make sense so
then the person say look it's a mystery
you just got to have faith of right of
course Islam it's not like that
there's reason there's reason I
knowledgebase course I'm not a bear I'm
not as strong as a bear I'm not as fast
as the cheetah al-ahzar gel made us with
the brain with knowledge in the Quran
Allah describes great item and and part
them the names with with the brand power
that's what we have and if the creator
of all things creates you with this
blessing and your belief in him is
contradictory to what your blessing
allows you to know that I think or to
compute doesn't make sense that's really
logical if it is illogical if you went
to a million people I mean this is just
you know you don't have to be a rocket
scientist they never heard about Islam
or Christianity and you presented them
with the uniqueness of God that we just
worship God or you try to explain this
whole concept of God the Father Son Holy
Ghost three one who died who did he pray
to what happened a hundred percent when
he died who ran the universe doesn't
make sense cannot add up those million
people who had a clear view they would
accept the worship of only one guy
bismillah hopefully we got to do a lot
of work too you have a lot of work to do
tell us now tell us now tell us look so
how can people be convinced now we said
it's knowledge base like we provide
evidence and this is really for a lot of
people that's like hey far-fetched later
we what evidence you talking about give
us something that people from now they
can look into Islam and know that you
know Islam is definitely not man-made
but it's from the Creator and Islam
simply means submission to the will of
God into the will of God where do I give
us something that oh one yeah I don't
you could talk about the death to be
sincere yes
sincere and finding the truth if there
is Allah and he wants you to be a Muslim
and if you are sincere about it there's
no way in Charlie will not become a
Muslim if you are truly sincere you will
find the truth how many stories do we
know of people they go for Buddhism
Hinduism you move through this and that
it finally Sam hua fitrah this is
perfect the nature of the nature of
mankind and this is it goes it's aligned
with your grain you know you get the hue
in wavelength I don't know it just it's
so it's made for mankind
number two the best the biggest miracle
of our prophet sallallahu alaihi Salam
is the Quran it is the Quran a living
miracle it is the living miracle that we
will have la ami action until the last
day
never never never in the history at a
linesman has someone been able to copy
it to mimic it to write another verse
like this one and this is a proof of the
Quran I believe it let me recap this is
proof of the Quran and it is the only
book that gives a shout out to people
mimic me if you mimic it do you don't
have to believe it it is the only boat
that calls out the people to do to go
through a challenge until this day no
one has ever been able to come close to
come close
it is a linguistic miracle I myself am
who I'm french-canadian I took Arabic
studies for for two years in the
university back home
you cannot come close to the Arabic of
the Quran it is untouchable untouchable
linguistic miracle and our prophet
sallallaahu Allison was unlettered he
did not know how to read and write so
this is beyond comprehension and number
three the science the math and then the
miracles in the Quran just one example I
believe in salat the room where at last
Vijaya describes the Bible the battle
between the Romans in the Byzantine army
they will fight where ad then I Lord the
lowest part of on the planet and today
with geology the whole nine it is
actually the lowest part on this globe
the lowest below sea level how could
anybody know this back in the day this
is just one one piece there are
thousands of miracles of the Quran go
back to the Quran and number four yeah
read on who is the prophet sallallaahu I
listen who is this man he was a man like
you and I he died he was born he normal
human being but he received revelation
from Allah so again before revelation
afterwards the stuff that he's
accomplished no regular human being
could have just done this without the
help of Allah such a clear message to
humanity and as well till this day the
Quran has
never been changed never been changed
and like like the first part there are
many different Bibles many different
books like this different version the
Quran Allah so jet promised mankind I
will protect this book I will protect
this book and that for me is this
wake-up call you know read up on Islam
really figure out research what it is
that Muslims believe what is it that we
are pushed to do how to behave o'clock
the good deeds there's no way you can
say no to this if you are sincere
sincere if you're sincere yes
if you're sincere there's no way you can
evidence is overwhelming it is
overwhelming it is overwhelming
Allah is would if I would if I was to
build a door if I was to build a door
there's no way that the door assembled
me I do not look like the door in my
mind I have skin this is made of wood or
metal and allow that I created the
universe and he is beyond this universe
way more complex in this universe
you can't even imagine and and just say
that he created man in His image I make
lots of mistakes to say that he became
man and died you can't allow yourself to
believe this you cannot allow yourself
to believe this we believe in Jesus Ali
Sam and let me see heaven Maryam the
said that the Messiah born of Mary many
miracles if you are sincere you will
accept Islam I can't I can't say it
enough if I had to one-on-one if I had a
one-on-one conversation with a Christian
many times in the past it did it ends
with complete silence and pure
contemplation have you had those have
you had some Christians accept us on Oh
My gods
yes how I got in spin yes yeah and I ask
you about when I when I take a break and
we right back with more here on the D
show with brother Phil it's like when
did you think that
you had no purpose are you worthless the
value comes from purpose your purpose in
life is to worship the Creator no
worship your desires himself not worship
social pressure the celebrity culture
but worship the thing that's much higher
and transcendent above and beyond by
worshipping God and seeking his pleasure
you get pleased so you have double
pleasure miss Miller what if I told you
that Islam is rooted in the word peace
what if I told you you've been deceived
in what a practicing Muslim actually
believes what if I told you that it's
Lam explains this life's meaning was
made for our Lord's pleasing made for
all from the blind to the seeing from
the old to the teething for all human
beings let go of your faith we
fabricated beliefs that are totally
obsolete held in the Wesen in some of
our Muslim countries in the East it's
time to be loud and proud about a
testimonial Val I testify that God is
unique and Muhammad is His Prophet and -
the reason why we constantly bow alone
or with the crowd how ironic the
religion of peace and mercy is accused
of controversy here are just a few of
its ruins and if your attention there
worthy to kill an innocent life is as
though you've killed all of humanity
back here on the Deen show we have our
brother who is French French Canadian
French Canadian and you were born again
Christian yes we went through the whole
you know void in your heart not knowing
what the purpose of life is to realizing
that there's a purpose in life and you
thought that Christianity was the way
and then you met a Muslim and he
provided you with the evidences and
proved to you that Islam which means
submission to the will of God that Jesus
do Islam absolutely the Moses doing so
absolutely Abraham all the messengers
all Muslims I did Islam's that real
question of that so much as how was that
the thing is Aslam means to submit like
you just said if someone obeys the
commandments of the creator he is under
the fold of Islam now that the
jurisprudence the fifth
of different profits and then the whole
nine sure it changed throughout
throughout the time different periods in
mankind but la ilahe loma to obey allah
alone and to submit to him
every prophet did this every prophet did
so you're still you're doing what Jesus
did you're submitting to the Creator not
his creation absolutely so now you still
love me no understand we'll go to hell
we'll go to hell if we don't believe in
Jesus is that right if you don't believe
that he was a mighty messenger
if you throw throw him out say look I'll
just take Moses and Abraham Mohammed but
leave out Jesus you can't do the good if
you know that you have to accept him you
know that you have to accept them that
you have reject you can't reject because
we know the Quran is directly from Allah
so JAL Larry Buffy ho Daniela McDuck
there's no doubt in it yeah if you're
gonna doubt it then you left the fold do
this even you don't believe in a
revelation anymore you know what's so
little time we're almost out of course
give us a just short glimpse of a
conversation you had with another
born-again Christian or a Christian and
they how did they come to assail so pan
Allah a few Ramadan's ago a brother came
in and he had Christian no no Muslim
Muslim but he brought a Christian friend
in Ramallah at the [ __ ] Carraway and
that night I didn't pray taraweeh but I
was just with the brother the whole time
we were going back and forth back and
forth what a Muslim has to do when
giving the hour is to not be on the
passenger side take control you have
Huck you have the truth so don't be on
the passenger side obviously don't be me
or don't be impolite and at the same
time you don't break someone's house and
then invite them to your house
you tell try to make back my house try
to do renovations here and there so the
whole idea of giving Dawa is to invite
to a slab invite you let allahu allah
muhammad rasool allah has laid it means
i testify there is no deity but God that
is the only one unique and that you can
worship and that muhammad is his final
prophets
isn't that the same statement you would
make if you were living during the time
of jesus that there's no deity where
they worship
absolutely and jesus i messily at that
time and at that time if someone did it
see be a muslim yeah and then so on and
so now you got accept the final
messenger privately there
no other pilgrimage on earth that you
can go to and see Filipino Muslims
Mexican Muslims Canadian Muslims Arab
Muslims African Muslims and with Allahu
Akbar we all do the same movements this
is a clear sign that the prophet
sallallaahu is a peace be upon him was
sent to all of mankind not to one nation
not to one nation and in the Bible the
disciples of Jesus are like listen some
ladies coming and she wants you to heal
her daughter or something and he replies
tell her that the master does not give
food to the dog because she was a nun
yet she was a gentle wasn't on Jew and
he clearly and the clear open statement
statement he says I was not sent unto
the lost children of the tribe of it
that was a medium issue clear statement
is this what you're telling the guy now
all of us and then what happens it of
course then I talk about the the
statement which is ELISA Lam says I must
hasten farmers go for the comforter shun
calm for them this is the holy spirit
but it cannot be the holy spirit just
with the the other statement juice arias
and I'm replies he will not come until I
leave but throughout the Bible the Holy
Spirit is mentioned and many things
happen so it cannot be the Holy Spirit
and he shall abide with you forever we
have the Quran we have a hadith the most
documented man in the world history is
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon and
we have Quran his final miracle his
teachings are still here if you
everything from the way he walked from
the way he spoke from the way he he put
on his shoes we know he spoke to people
from the way combed his hair it's
narrated how many great bids he has in
his I'm gonna get ya you everything so
Peron Allah everything is there he is
he's his merkel is still here in Austria
I promise that it will will stay with us
forever for the French person out there
that he heard French and he don't speak
too much English just real quick
can you say something in French worship
the Creator not as Christian something
I'll stick with him and Dulla in France
in French absolutely something up lazier
tell us on do a delicate our salute to K
sin not sin at present date a lick on a
present date cannot cetera called
Sukeena to help all new
the only people activity on a people
activity in the economy G in my medicine
prefer Karapetyan juice was solely so
Lala Hawaii will send them just by photo
ma ke we fed with lecture Seoul Islam
caseless Lam yoga deepali music Mac song
flan flan I'd prefer regarded gamma s
Clicquot Agudelo context historic fed
back like Joseph Keaton my med
sallallaahu I am clip a Lebanese on the
Alonso Jets was surely we are out of
time worker people if they they want to
get a hold of you you know if they've
some born again Christian now he's like
you know what just makes sense I've been
struggling with this whole you know
Trinity in that and this guy was that he
was a born-again Christian I want to
talk to him how could I can countries
finding me on facebook.com / dawa on my
youtube channel Dowell Phil you can
email me Dowell Phil at gmail.com please
I want to get the word out obviously
this is an a man is a big trust on us to
spread this message and look at my
videos my poetry that I've done let's
get together online and then we'll see
what we can do in Shaba thank you very
much for being with us a very incredible
story had more times my pleasure is I
can look at another word you like sir
and there you have it the message
delivered to you in French worship the
Creator not his creation think about the
purpose of life where you're going
aslam makes it simple a law says in the
Quran if you choose other anyone who
chooses another way of life other than
submission to the will of God Islam
never will it be accepted of him no word
that Jesus Christ peace be upon him who
we love no Muslim is a Muslim unless you
believe in Jesus that he was one of the
mightiest messengers no where did he
ever explicitly call people to worship
him or his mother nor did any messenger
of God they all call people to worship
God not themselves and this is the same
message of all the messengers including
the last and final messenger problem and
peace be upon them
so when you realize deaf is a reality
the day of judgment is a reality
Hellfire is true and that's eternal you
go there forever
paradise is real is eternal and all you
have to do is ask
to guide you ask God to guide you repent
to him call upon him worship the Creator
not his creation all is that is
explained in Islam 1-866 to Islam to
learn more and we'll see you next time
peace be unto you